شكرا للزميل نايف اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل
خير اعزائي المشاهدين واهلا بكم الى هذه
الساعه الاخباريه التي نخصص معظمها لتغطيه
التطورات في السودان هذه ابرز العناوين
السعوديه تؤكد على ضروره التهدئه في
السودان وتغليب المصلحه الوطنيه والقاهره
تحذر من التدخلات الخارجيه
جيش السودان يعلن تدمير ارتال عسكريه
للقوات الدعم والاخيره تتهم كتائب الامن
الشعبي بدخول المعركه
الا في نص كبير في فاسيدس المستشفى
نقابه اطباء السودان تشكو من صعوبه الوصول
لمخازن الدواء وتخشى مشكلات بيئيه
وبيولوجيه خطيره جراء الحرب
وفي هذه الساعه الاخباريه ايضا
يؤكد ان كييف جاهزه للهجوم المضاد حتى
بدون المقاتلات الغربيه وروسيا تحصن
مواقعها عبر شبكه خنادق
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا نواصل هذه التغطيه
المتواصله للتطورات الدراماتيكيه في
السودان وفي جديدها استمرار للشبكات
المتقطعه وتبادل الاتهامات بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع في اخر ايام الهدنه
الخامسه واليوم
ظهر جدل جديد حول دخول ما يسمى بالامن
الشعبي في المعارك وهو ما اكدته قوات
الدعم ونفته الشرطه السودانيه
سياسيا طالبت الرياض مجددا بتغليب المصلحه
الوطنيه للسودان بينما حذرت القاهره من
التدخلات الخارجيه
حاليا نحن في المنطقه بتاعه المرسى
المواطنين السكان في المنطقه مثل بعض
ومناطق المجاوره
مباشره من النيل شيلوا مويه بتاعه شرب
شيلوها من النيل ومن هنا من المرسى وانت
ماشي فالناس جدعاني جدعاني شديد جدعان
تتحرك بيهم المناطق الصدريه
وهنا والمنطقه خطيره شديد يعني
[موسيقى]
هذا واستقبل وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان المبعوث الخاص
لرئيسي مجلس السياده الانتقالي السوداني
السفير دفع الله الحاج علي وجرى خلال لقاء
بحث الاوضاع الراهنه في السودان وقد اكد
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه على دعوه الرياض
للتهدئه وتغذيب المصلحه الوطنيه ووقف كل
اشكال التصعيد العسكري بما يحافظ على
مقدرات ومكتسبات السودان وشعبه
من جهاته دعا الامين العام لمجلس التعاون
الخليجي جاسم محمد البديوي الى تغليب
مصلحه السودان الوطنيه وذلك خلال لقائه
المبعوث الخاص لرئيس مجلس السياده
الانتقالي بالسودان دفع الله الحاج علي
كما دعا امين عام مجلس التعاون الى
التهدئه ووقف كل اشكال التصعيد في السودان
مؤكدان الحرص على امن السودان وسلامته
واستقراره وتماسك الدوله السودانيه
ومؤسساتها وشدد على مسانده مجلس التعاون
الخليجي للسودان لمواجهه كافه التحديات
وتحقيق تطلعات شعبه
هذا واكد الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
ضروره عدم التدخل الخارجي في الازمه
السودانيه كما اكد السيسي في مؤتمر صحفي
المشترك مع رئيس الوزراء الياباني
على ضروره الوقف الفوري والدائم لاطلاق
النار في السودان
في هذه الاثناء حضر المتحدث باسم العمليه
السياسيه في السودان خالد عمر يوسف حذر من
انتشار المواجهات الاثنيه
والقوميه في البلاد في ظل احتدام الاقتتال
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع واضاف يوسف
ان استمرار الحرب لا يبدو انه سينتهي
بانتصار طرف على اخر كما انه سيفتح بابا
للمواجهات الاثنيه في كل البلاد ولن تصبح
هناك دوله بالاساس
المبعوث الامريكي الخاص السابق الى القرن
الافريقي من كان قد حذر هو الاخر في لقاء
مع صحيفه الجاردن من اطاله امد الصراع في
السودان لانه سيفتح الباب امام جهات
خارجيه تدعم جنرال على حساب اخر
الصراع في السودان الى منحا اخر وربما
ينتهي بتدخل خارجي لنصره احد جنرال النزاع
ما ينذر بحرب اهليه طويله الامد تقول
صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيه
الصحيفه نقلت عن الدبلوماسي الامريكي
ومبعوثها الخاص السابق الى القرن الافريقي
جيفري قوله انه كلما طال امد الصراع سيسمح
لجهات خارجيه خبيثه بدعم جنرال على حساب
اخر
رجل امريكا السابق للقرن الافريقي اكد على
ان الساحه متاحه امام القوات الخارجيه في
اشاره الى مجموعه فاكنير الروسيه ولذلك
يتوجب وقف الاقتتال في اسرع وقت ممكن
لتقويد التحرك الخارجي
تحذيراتمان لم تاتي من فراغ على ما يبدو
بعد ان كشف القائد السابق لفاينر مرات
جابدول للجاردن ان فارجنر موجوده في
السودان منذ نهايه العام
2017 مؤكدا ان هناك 200 عنصر من الوحده
الهجوميه الاولى داخل الاراضي السودانيه
حيث كانت مكلفه بتدريب قوات الدعم السريع
والشرطه المحليه
التحذيرات جاءت ايضا من الداخل على لسان
قائد جيش عبد الفتاح البرهان الذي كشف عن
وجود مرتزقه داخل السودان قدمت من دول
تشاد
هي الوسطى والنيجر
رئيس الوزراء السوداني السابق عبد الله
حمدوك حذر هو الاخر من امكانيه اندلاع حرب
اهليه في السودان ستشكل كابوسا قاطما على
البلاد والعالم محاسن حداره العربيه
ميدانيا ومع دخول المعارك بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع اسبوع الثالث تجددت
الاشتباكات حيث شهدت منطقتها المهندسين
والصالحه مواجهات بالاسلحه الخفيفه
والثقيله وقصف بالطيران بحسب مراسل
العربيه وافاد شهود عيان من الحلفايه شمال
مدينه الخرطوم بحري ببدء الجيش في نشر
وحداته والقيام بعمليات تمشيط بعد معارك
عنيفه شهدتها المنطقه هذا وتجدد سماعه دوي
في جراث واصوات اطلاق نار في محيط القياده
العامه للجيش
قوات الدعم السريع اتهمت هي الاخرى الجيش
بمهاجمه مواقع تمركزها في عدد من مناطق
الخرطوم بالمدافع والطائره
بيان الدعم السريع اشار الى ان طائرات
الجيش ما تزال تحلق في سماء الخرطوم
وتنتهك الهدنه الدعم السريع قال ان الجيش
يستعد لشن هجوم في العاصمه الخرطوم ومدينه
الحلفايه وام دربان وبحري
اكدت الشرطه السودانيه ان قوات الاحتياطي
المركزي فصيل تابع لها وقد تم الدفع به
الى الشوارع لتامين الاسواق وممتلكات
المواطنين
وشددت على ان من يقودها وهم خريجوه كليه
الشرطه والقانون
وقالت الشرطه ردا على الدعم السريع في
البيان انه لا وجود للامن الشعبي في قوات
الاحتياطي المركزي مؤكده بان مقر البنك
المركزي الرئيسي لم يتعرض لاي هجوم وان
الحريق الذي تم الاعلان عنه يعود لاحد
فروع البنك
السودان اسبوع ثالث من القتال
مخاوف من ان يؤدي الصراع الى حرب طويله
الامد
صراع انفجر منتصف ابريل ولم يهدا بعد
طرف صراع الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع
قرر المواجهه بالسلاح والتبادل الاتهامات
اعلاميا
حصيله كبيره من القتلى والجرحى
الاف الفرينه الى دول الجوار وعمليات
اجلاء كبيره ومستمره
واستظروف انسانيه صعبه
هدنه معلنه وجهود دوليه لوقف القتال
لكن اعمده الدخان لم تغب عن سماء الخرطوم
من الخرطوم ينضم اليه المزيد من المتابعه
مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي سالم اهلا
وسهلا بك جديد المشهد الميداني ابرز
مشاهداتك وهل ما زالت الهدنه صامده بشكل
او باخر
مع اهلا بك وبكل الساده المشاهدين ما زالت
هذه الهدنه الى حد ما هي الافضل منذ بدا
هذه الهدنات هناك تحسن يتم هدنه بعد هدنه
هذا بالاضافه الى بعض الحركه شبه الطبيعيه
في مناطق متفرقه من العاصمه
من مدينه ام درمان ان هناك تجدد
للاشتباكات او سماع لاصوات لمدافع ثقيله
وخفيفه في النواحي الغربيه من ام درمان
ولم نتبين التفاصيل بعد حول هذا الموضوع
لكن هنالك اصوات لمدافع وكذلك اصوات
لمضادات طائرات كذلك هنا في الخرطوم هي
الاقل في هذا اليوم في موضوع الاشتباكات
بعدها مدينه بحري ثمانيه هذا هو ترتيب
المدن بالنسبه
للاصوات التي تصدر يوميا في تجدد
الاشتباكات من مدافع ثقيله وخفيفه واصوات
الطائرات يضاف اليها مضادات الطائرات كذلك
ربما الخرطوم هي الاقل نسبيا وهي الاكثر
حركيه في النواحي البعيده من مناطق
الاشتباكات اي البعيده من مطار الخرطوم
والبعيده من القياده العامه والبعيده كذلك
من القصر الرئاسي ربما هناك تشهد حركه ولو
طفيفه بعض المحل التجاريه بدات كذلك هناك
الاسواق البعيده كذلك من هذه المناطق بدات
فيها الحياه شبه طبيعيه
هل هنالك كلام عن امكانيه تمديد الهدنه
الاثنتين وسبعين ساعه اضافيه وهل هذا
متوقع سالم وفق متابعتك
لتصريحات ومواقف الطرفين انا لا اسمعك هل
تسمعني الان سالم
سالم انت على الهواء هل تسمعني اعيد عليك
السؤال اذا كنت تسمعني من قطع الاتصال معك
يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال هنالك مشكله في
الاتصالات منذ نحو ثلاثه اسابيع نتيجه هذا
الاقتتال الدائر على كل ربما لا نعود الى
سالم فور جهوز الاتصال مجددا قال رئيس حزب
الامه السودانيين بارك الفاضل المهدي
للعربي ان قوات الدعم السريع اقتحمت منزله
وسرقته واتلفت عددا من الوثائق
دخلوا البيت
وكسروا البيت
وكانوا يبحث ايضا عن وسائق لانهم بعثروا
كثير من الوثائق ليس فقط انهم كسروا الخزن
واخذوا ذهب السيدات وغيره لكن كانوا يبحث
عنك في كان ينظر في الوثائق
الخاصه بي
فاكره كثير من هذه الوثائق
ورموها على الارض بشكل يعني واضح
كما اضاف ان سبب الاقتحام هو ان حزبه وقف
مع الجيش السوداني في ظل الصراع الحالي مع
قوات الدعم السريع
نحن
وقفنا مع القوات المسلحه السودانيه وانا
هناك في السودان الاسبوع الماضي اصدرت
بيان
تاييد للقوات المسلحه السودانيه ورفض لهذا
الهجوم
العسكري من قبل قوات الدعم السريع وانا
كانت ليست نقاشات مع الفريق مع محمد
حمدانو
وهو في مرحله عرض عليه التحالف معه في
بدايه هذا العام
وانا نصحته
بعدم
مواجهه القوات المسلحه
واعتذرت عن اي تحالف في مواجهه القوات
المسلحه
المهدي قال ان قوات الدعم السريع فيها عدد
من مقاتله بوكو حرام وغيرها وقد حاولوا
الهرب لكن تم القبض عليهم على الحدود
هذه قوات فيها عدد كبير جدا من بوكو حرام
من نيجيريا ومن مالي ومن النيجر وحتى من
من موريتانيا والان عدد كبير منهم الان
لجا في
محاولا يهرب وتم
التحفظ عليه في الحدود التشاديه الان اكثر
من الف اجنبي من هذه الدول تم التحفظ
عليهم في الحدود الاستشاديه ونحن على صله
مع المسؤولين هناك في ادري
وعلى خلفيه الموجات المسلحه المستمره بدا
موظفون في ولايه الخرطوم عطله رسميه حتى
اشعار اخر وذلك بسبب الظروف الامنيه التي
تعيشها البلاد ولا تشمل العطله غرف اداره
الازمه والمرافق الخدميه الحيويه
في سياق متصل اعلنت ولايه الغضارف ونهر
النيل في السودان حاله الطوارئ لمواجهه
تداعيات الاشتباكات الجاريه حاليا في
البلاد حيث امر والي القضارف باعلان حاله
طوارئ لمده شهر مؤكدا ان من يخالف الاوامر
يعرض نفسه للغرامه او السجن هذا واعلن
والي نهر النيل ايضا حاله الطوارئ
بالولايه ووجه الجهات المختصه
بتنفيذ الامر وفق وسائل على محليه
اما في ولايه غرب دارفور فقد اعلن ثقابه
الاطباء حصرا 94 حاله وفاه جراء
الاشتباكات في مدينه الجنينه قبل ذلك اعلن
الجيش السوداني في بيان له ان لجنه امن
الولايه نجحت بالحد من التوتر القبلي وان
شرطه الاحتياطي تفتح تدريجيا مناطق في
جنوب الخرطوم الجيش السوداني اشار في
بيانه الى ان الموقف العملياتي مستقر في
جميع المناطق العسكريه بالبلاد مؤكدان
استمرارا بعض الدول باجلاء رعاياها من
الخرطوم وبورتسودا
من جنوب اقليم دارفور ينضم الي الصحفي
صالح ابو علامه سيد صالح اهلا وسهلا بك
اولا
المشهد من جنوب اقليم دارفور كيف يبدو اذا
كان لديكم اي داله على ما يجري في الجنينه
نعرف انه بعيده الى حد ما ولكن هل مازال
هنالك صراع قبلي في تلك المنطقه
نعم نحن اليوم في جنوب دارفور دعني انقل
لك المشهد حيث انا هنا في اكبر مستودع
للغذاء الذره وغيره من المشتقات الغذائيه
تم حرق هذا المجمع بالكامل
وحرصت هنا في هذه المجمع اكثر من عشره الف
جوال من الذره وعدد كبير جدا من المواد
الغذائيه المهمه جدا لسكان هنا في جنوب
دارفور كل هذه الاحداث دارت جراء من هي
الجهه التي قامت باحراق هذه المحاصيل يا
سيد صالح اذا كان لديك معلومات
[موسيقى]
للحرب الدائره وكل هذه الاشياء لها اثر
كبير جدا في المخزون الاستراتيجي في الوضع
الغذائي المتردي سي السابق وحتى حتى الان
يعني هذه الحراير تزيد من الوضع الغذائي
المتردد جدا في ولايه دارفور نعلم بانه
ايضا تمت سرقه المخازن التابعه لبرنامج
العالمي ايضا في جنوب دارفور وفي مواقع
اخرى ايضا من ولايات دارفور ضرر كبير جدا
احدثه هذا الصراع وفي هذا الوقت لا توجد
اي معالجات حسب ايضا حديثنا مع
المتضررين لا توجد معالجات نسبه لعدم وجود
اي سلطه يمكن ان تعوض هذه الخسائر طيب
الخسائر مقتصره على الماديات وعلى
الامور والسلع الغذائيه ام لا في خسائر
بالارواح السيد صالح نتيجه هذه الاشتباكات
نعم هنالك خسائر بالارواح قبل يومين
انفجرت عبوه ناسفه في شباب في حي ماجوق
وفتره خمسه من الشباب وايضا جراء هذه
الاشتباكات قتل عدد
من المواطنين داخل احياء نياله هنالك
تدمير لبعض المباني دائما في المدن
السودانيه نجد قياده الجيش تكون في وسط
الاحياء
ويكون بالقرب منها عدد كبير جدا من
المنازل هذه الاشياء هذا الثقل القريب من
الحاميه تسبب في اضرار كبيره جدا
للمواطنين هنالك جرحه وهنالك قتله وهنالك
نزوح ايضا من بعض الاحياء
طيب الحديث عن صراع قبلي واثني
هل يعني يمكن لمسه هل ام لا يعني
الصراع والاشتباكات تتم بين قوات الدعم
السريع
والجيش ام لا في صراع قبلي كما يجري
الحديث عنه وفي صراع اثني ايضا وربما صراع
قوميات متضاربه في تلك المنطقه
نعم ما يحرك الصراع القوميات هي عمليات
النهب والسلب وعدم حمايه المواطنين اليوم
كل شخص يحمي
محله تجاري يحمي منزله
سيد صالح
يبدو ان فقدنا الاتصال مع صالح ابو علامه
يعني كما يحدث خراب في موقع ما
يتصارع الاثنين وبعد ذلك تتوسع رقعه
الصراع وتشمل القبيله هذا ما يحدث تحديدا
وهذا ما حدث ايضا في غرب دارفور مدينه
الجنينه اختراع في الجنينه حتى الان الوضع
هنالك نعم توقف لاصوات الرصاص هنالك توقف
الاشتباكات لكن لماذا الوضع الامني غير
مطمئن ابدا في البنينه نعم السوق الكبير
اللي انا حتى الان لم يفتح لكن هنالك
اسواق صرفيه فتحت لكن كل هذا الهدوء هو
هدوء هذه نسبه لعدم تدخل اي جهه
لاستذباب الامن وللطمنه المواطنين في غرب
دارفور من جنوب اقليم دارفور الصحفي صالح
ابو علامه شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
حاليا احنا في المنطقه بتاعت المرسى بس
المواطنين السكان في المنطقه
المجاوره من هنا مباشره من النيل شيلو
مويه بتاعت شرب شيلوها من النيل ومن هنا
من المرسى وانت ماشي فالناس بتعاني بدعاني
شديد جدعاني
تتحرك فيهم المناطق السكنيه كلها تجيبيه
وهنا والمنطقه خطيره شديد يعني
[موسيقى]
وفي متابعه للاوضاع الصحيه اعلنت نقابه
الاطباء في السودان ارتفاع عدد القتلى
المدنيين جراء الاشتباكات الى 425 شخصا
واصابه الفين واحد وتسعين اخرين
واشارت النقابه الى ان 16 مستشفى تعرض
للقصف منذ بدايه المواجهات حيث طالت
عمليات القصف مستشفى البراحه في الخرطوم
بحري يوم امس
وحذرت النقابه من ان السودان معرضون
لمشكلات بيئيه وبيولوجيه خطيره
من جهاته قال المفوض الاوروبي لاداره
الازمات جينز ان خطرا انتشار الازمه
السودانيه الى الدول المجاوره في المنطقه
امر غير مستبعد وهو خطر حقيقي واضاف
المفوض الاوروبي لاداره الازمات ان هناك
دولا ضعيفه للغايه بينها دول مجاوره
للسودان وبالتالي فان عواقب تصعيد الصراع
ستكون كارثيه كما شدد المفوض الاوروبي على
ان المصالحه بين الطرفين المتعارضين في
السودان يجب ان تكون على راس الاولويات
والجهود الدوليه المبذوله لوقف اطلاق
النار
من جانبه حذر عطيه عبد الله سكرتير نقابه
اطباء السودان في تصريحاته للعربيه حذر من
انهيار النظام الصحي في البلاد وقال ان
هذا الانهيار اصبح وشيكا بسبب عدم توفر
الادويه والملزمات الطبيه اللازمه لتقديم
العلاج
الصحي اصبح وشيكا فان نراه راي العين
تدهور تام في الخدمات الطبيه في
المستشفيات نقص حاد في المعينات الطبيه
عدم القدره الى الوصول الى المستشفيات من
الكوادر الطبيه او الاسعاف
نقص حاد في اكياس الدم نقص حاد في
معينات غسيل الكلى نقطه حاد في الادويه
المنقذه للحياه والادويه المستخدمه في
العمليات الجراحيه النقص في كل مكان
يكاد نكون وصلنا الى المرحله الصفريه في
عدد من المعينات الطبيه الضروريه
نحاول عبد الله قال ايضا للعربيه ان هناك
مخاوف حقيقيه من ان تصل البلاد الى وقت لا
تستطيع فيه الكوادر الطبيه تاديه واجباتها
بسبب القتال نحن نتخوف من تاتي لحظه لا
يستطيع الكادر الطبي القيام بواجبه المهني
والاخلاقي نريد كاولويه الان هي الوقف هذه
الحرب فورا ومن ثم فتح ممرات امنه للوصول
الى المستشفيات وايضا فتح كل المخازن
الامدادات الطبيه داخل وخارج الخرطوم الى
وتغذيه المستشفيات فتح المجال الجوي
والبري والبحري للمعينات الانسانيه من
الدول الصديقه والمحبه للشعب السوداني
ايضا نحن نطالب بعدم استهداف الكوادر
الطبيه وعدم استهداف المنشات الطبيه
من جانبها قالت رئيسه العمليات الميدانيه
لليونيسف في السودان جيل لولر في بيان
الله قالت ان اليونيسف على درايه بان هناك
اكثر من 15 مليون شخص بحاجه الى المساعدات
الانسانيه مؤكده ان الوضع الحالي الذي
يشهده السودان من قصف وهجمات هو في تزايد
ما بان قبل حدوث ازمه السودان الحاليه
هناك اكثر من 15 مليون شخص بحاجه الى
المساعدات الانسانيه من بينهم ثمانيه
ملايين طفل وان القصف الجوي والهجمات على
البنيه التحتيه للمياه وتدمير اللقاحات
الحيويه التي تشهدها البلاد ستكون في
ارتفاع ملحوظ
وافادت رئيسه العمليات الميدانيه لليونيسف
ايضا بان الوضع في السودان لا يساعد
العاملين في المجال الانساني لايصال
الخدمات الى المحتاجين مؤكده اما بعض
العاملين تعرضوا للهجوم
القصف والصراع وانعدام الامن في البلاد لا
تساعد العاملين في المجال الانساني بايصال
الخدمات الى المحتاجين لقد تعرض بعض
العاملين في المجال الانساني للهجوم
بالاضافه الى من لقي حتفه في الطريق الوضع
في غايه الصعوبه
ومع استمرار الاشتباكات يزداد الضغط على
القطاع الصحي في السودان حتى اصبح الحديث
عن انهيار النظام الصحي امرا غير مستبعا
من سيء الى اسوا انهيار النظام الصحي في
السودان بات وشيكا في كل يوم يزداد عدد
المرافق الصحيه التي تخرج عن الخدمه
الواحده تلو الاخرى جراء القصف او نقص
المعدات والمستلزمات الطبيه او بسبب غياب
الكوادر الطبيه وضع اذا استمر وبنفس
الوتيره سيهدد وقريبا بالاغلاق التام
لكافه المرافق الصحيه الرسميه في ظل تواصل
العمليات العسكريه وفقا لنقابه الاطباء
السودانيه لكن الذي اريد ان اؤكده ان
هنالك ليس هنالك ضمانات للممرات الامنه
فهنالك ما يحدث في الجنينين انما هي مبدا
انسانيه مجزره بشريه مخالب لكل
القوانين الدوليه غياب الممره كذلك خلال
الهدنه التي يتم خرقها في كل مره سبب
رئيسي لعزل هذه المرافق الحيويه وجعلها
مكانا خطيرا لا يمكن الوصول اليه مع
استباحه واستهداف كل من طرفي نزاع لها لا
يقتصر انهيار النظام الصحي فقط على مناطق
الاشتباكات بالخرطوم بل يمتدوا الى جميع
الاقاليم التي تاثرت بانقطاع الامداد
الدوائي ونزوح الاطباء خارج البلاد
الجثث عددها كبيره جدا واحد اثنين اتساعا
للرقعه الجغرافيه بتاعه ولايه الخرطوم
يعني ان احنا لو عايزين نغطي ولايه
الخرطوم كلها بمحليات السبعه هي هي حاجه
ضخمه جدا
ارتفاع اعداد المصابين تسبب ايضا بالضغط
على القطاع الصحي واستنزاف الموارد
الموجوده
حيث شهدت مدينه كسلا الواقعه في اقصى
الشرق والتي تبعد قرابه 600 كيلومتر عن
الخرطوم نقصا حدا في اسطوانات الاكسجين
فضلا عن انعدام اكياس الدم بانحاء الولايه
كالرمحناوي العربيه
تفاقم الاوضاع الطبيه انعكس على قطاع
الادويه حيث ازدادت ازمه نقص الادويه في
الخرطوم مع استمرار المواجهات المسلحه
وحضر تجمع الصياد الى المهنيين بالسودان
من كارهه صحيه بسبب عمليات نهب الصيدليات
وشركات ومخازن الادويه في مدن العاصمه
الثلاث بالتزامن مع اغلاق عدد كبير من
الصيدليات في ام درمان
الخلصه عندنا تماما او على وشك هي ادويه
الضغط وادويه السكري
والادويه بتشتغل على الجهاز العصبي او
الادويه التعسير العصبي
خصوصا مرضى الصرع
طبعا اساسا عندهم مشكله في الحي الادويه
دي اساسا ما متوفر في الظروف العاديه فيها
شح والان المشكله بقت اكبر بالاضافه للفوط
الصحيه
للسيدات تكاد تكون الان ما موجوده خالص
كمان مشكله الالبان عند الاطفال دي مشكله
كارثه حقيقيه الان الالبان غير موجوده
وجدت الاحداث الدوحه
انسانين
مخلوط ومعاوى الحقن او تفتش وما خلوا اي
حته فتش عشان القليل
خلينا صيدليه ما لقينا ما خلينا حتى ما
لقينا
[موسيقى]
حاليا الادويه
الخلاصه عندنا تماما او على وشك يا ادويه
الضغط
[موسيقى]
وجدت الاحداث الدو حقك تنسالين
مخلوط ومعاوى الحقن ولدها يفتش وما خلوه
اي حته فتش عشان تقولي
[موسيقى]
وفي ميناء بورسودان وصلت اليوم اول شحنه
لمساعدات انسانيه من الصليب الاحمر جوا
ضمن عمليه الطوارئ التي ينفذها منذ اندلاع
المعارف في السودان وافاد بيان للجنه
الدوريه للصليب الاحمر بان الشحنه التي
ارسلت من عمان تزنوا ثمانيه اطنان وتضمنت
معدات جراحيه لدعم المستشفيات ومتطوعين من
جمعيه هلال الاحمر السوداني الذين يقدمون
الرعايه الطبيه
للجرحى الذين اصيبوا خلال القتال
معي من جناب كريستال ويلز وهي المتحدثه
الرسميه للجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
السيده كريستال اهلا وسهلا بك الى هذه
التغطيه من العربيه اي تقييم للاوضاع
الصحيه والانسانيه في السودان مع دخول هذه
المواجهات الاسبوع الثالث لها وما هي ابرز
مخاوفكم سيده كريستال
التي وصلت الى ميناء السودان اليوم وكلها
حيويه شاهدنا خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين
القيود التي تسبب بها هذا النزاع على
المنشات الصحيه في الخرطوم ومناطق اخرى
المتاثره بالقتال الاطباء والمريضون
وفعلوا المستحيل لمعالجه المرضى
بعدم وجود اي شيء لا كهرباء ولا مياه ولا
معدات طبيه ونحن نعرف بان المرضى يموتون
بسبب الافتقار الى هذه المؤن والمواد
الضروريه لتقديم الرعايه بالجرحى ان تكون
هذه المهنه التي واصلت وهي كما ذكرتم
ثمانيه اطنان
ومواد التسطيع
معالجه المئات والمئات من الاشخاص
الاطباء والمرضين وكذلك المتطوعين من
الهلال الاحمر السوداني لكي تنقذ الارواح
هنالك اشياء هم بحاجه شديده اليها
هل في الايام المقبله
والى اي طرف تسلم هذه الش من المساعدات
الى اي طرف يعني نحن نعرف ان هنالك طرفان
اساسيان في هذا القتال الى اي طرف ثالث
تسلم هذه المساعدات وما الضامن بانها تصل
الى مستحقيها من الناس هناك
الاول
هذه الشحنه الاولى ونعمل انها عديده في
المستقبل وعن قريب نعمل بارسالي عدد او
فرق الاستجابه للطوارئ لتعزيز استجابتنا
وكذلك المزيد من المؤمنين معهم خلال ايام
القادمه
نتمنى ان يكون هذا الشيء مستمر لكن يتمكن
من التقديم المزيد من الاغاثه
لتعزيز ودعم عملنا اما فيما يخص الى اين
تسلم فهي تذهب الى المستشفيات والهلال
الاحمر السوداني
والصليب الاحمر سيقدمه مباشره الاولويه
لفقراء على الارض الان ان تتحدث مع
الطرفين ومع طرفين النزاع لكي نضمن الحصول
على الضمانات الامنيه المناسبه لكي تتمكن
فرقنا من التحرك بامان ونصل الى الاماكن
التي نحن بحاجه اليها مثلا مستشفيات
الخرطوم التي واجهت قتالا شديدا خلال
الاسبوعين الماضيين
طب ما هي المعلومات التي تصلكم من الداخل
عن اوضاع المستشفيات القطاع الدوائي وكذلك
الصيدليات اي معلومات
الاوضاع مزريه ليس لديهم حتى المواد
الاساسيه من اجل معالجه المرضى او
المصابين المستشفيات ايضا بدات تنتدى
لمعالجه المصابين بالامراض المزمنه علاوه
على ذلك نحن نعرف ان العديد المستشفيات
تعاني من شحه المياه والكهرباء والبن
التحتيه الاساسيه
لتقوم بعملها كمستشفى وكذلك الاطباء
والممرضات يعانون من اجل الوصول الى
العملات العدائيه وشده القتال والمرضى
ايضا يعانون من اجل الوصول الى المستشفيات
لكي يتمكنوا من الحصول على العينايه
الضروريه منظمه الصحه العالميه قدرت ان
فقط 16% من المستشفيات في الخرطوم تعمل
الان وهذه احصائيه مخيفه جدا وتظهر كم
خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين تضرر النظام
الصحي في السودان بسبب هذا النزاع سيد
كريستيل هنالك معلومات وتقارير تحدثت عن
بدء انتشار اوبئه كالملاريا والكوليرا هل
انتم على اطلاع على ذلك ام لا هذا الكلام
غير صحيح وفيه مبالغات
هذا ليس بالشيء الذي استطيع ان اكده في
هذه اللحظه ولكن ما استطيع ان اقوله ومن
المهم ان ناخذه بنظام الاعتبار هما
مسالتان الاولى لانه حتى قبل هذا النزاع
او اندلاعها كانت هنالك ازمه انسانيه
كبيره في السودان فكر في الوضع مثلا في
دارفور حيث الملايين من الاشخاص يعانوا من
سنوات طويله من العلف والنزال وكذلك
الصدمات المناخيه مثل الفيضانات وفي اكثر
الاحيان وحتى قبل نزاع قبل اسبوعين كانوا
يعلم الاجل الحصول احتياجاتهم الاساسيه
والملاريا في هذا السياق ستكون مميته
وثانيا فيما يخص الكوليرا وكما قلت لا
استطيع ان اؤكد وجود حالات او اصابه
بالكوليرا ولكن هذا امر يقلقنا وان القتال
يحصل في مناطق مكتظه بالسكان وداخل المدن
وغالبا ما تستخدم فيه المتفجرات جديده
والتي يكون لها اثر كبير جدا على السكان
المدنيين سواء فيما يخص الاصاباتي او قتل
الارواح وكذلك اضرار
بالبناء التحتيه التي يعتمد عليها البشره
مثلا المياه
اود فقط ان اشدد على مدى اهميه ان نضمن
عدم استهداف المنشات او المنشات والكهرباء
لكي لا تتفشا الاوبئه
ابرز الاحتياجات والسلع العاجله التي يجب
ارسالها برايك بشكل فوري الى السودان في
هذا الوقت ما هي
كما قلت اليوم
لكي يحققوا الفارق في حيات هؤلاء
المحتاجين اليها من جنوب كريستال المتحدثه
الرسميه للجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه
هذا وتوقعت مفوضيه الامم المتحده الساميه
لحقوق الانسان ان تتضاعف اعداد اللاجئين
السودانيين مضيحه ان 75 الفا نزح داخليا
بينما فر اخرون الى دول الخارج بسبب
الازمه
وتلاجئا السودان ومع كل قصف يعكر
سماء تتضاعف اعداد نازحيه وتوقعات امميه
بفرار مئات الالاف مفوضيه الامم المتحده
قالت ما لا يقل عن 75 الف شخص نزحوا
داخليا بسبب الازمه فيما بلغ عدد المشردين
قرابه ثلاثه ملايين وسبعمائه الف شخص
معظمهم في منطقه غرب دارفور المضطربه
بينما سبعه وثلاثون الف شخص نزحوا عبر
مدينه نيالا و30 الفا توجهوا جنوبا الى
النيل الابيض فالسودان لم يعد ملاذا امنا
هرب اخرون الى الخارج التقديرات تشير الى
ان 20 الفا عبروا الى تشاد وقد ترتفع
الاعداد الى 100 الف بحسب المنظمه الدوليه
للهجره و14 اخرين اتجهوا الى مصر وذات
العدد لكن الى جنوب السودان اما اثيوبيا
فاستقبلت
3500 شخص
بالفرار الى افريقيا الوسطى
1300 بينهم 500 طفل وامراه
اكد المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع السعوديه
العميد الركن التركي المالكي للعربي ان
السعوديه مستمره في اجلائه رعايه الدول
الصديقه من السودان العمل الانساني مستمر
منذ بدايه الازمه في اخلاء الرعايه من
الدول الشقيقه والصديقه الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه اليوم في على سفينه
جلاله الملك الدرعيه نقلنا 52 من الرعايه
كان من ضمنهم من باكستان 15 من نيبال 19
من السودان ومن عمان سته ومن الجنسيه
الامريكيه عدد واحد نقول لهم الحمد لله
على السلامه وان شاء الله ان امورهم مرتبه
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ويسالون سالمين ان شاء الله الى اهاليهم
هذا وانا وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه ان
اجمالي من تم اجلائهم من السودان الى جده
وصل الى 513 شخصا ينتمون الى مئه دوله
واوضحت الخارجيه السعوديه انه تم اجلاء
خمسه واربعين مواطنا سعوديا وسته وثلاثين
شخصا من الجنسيه الباكستانيه اليوم من
السودان الى قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه
بالقطاع الغربي في جده
واكلت الخارجيه السعوديه ان المملكه وفرت
كل الاحتياجات الاساسيه لرعايه دول
الشقيقه والصديقه تمهيدا لتسهيل مغادرتهم
الى اوطانهم
والى الحدود المصريه السودانيه اظهرت صور
الاقمار الصناعيه اصطفاف عشرات الحافلات
على معبر اركين الحدودي تحمل الفارين من
النزاع الدائري في السودان واظهرت الصور
ازدحاما على المعبر في انتظار عبور
الحافلات الى الطرف المصري
مع من الخرطوم لمزيد من المتابعه والتحليل
الصحفي عمار ابو شيبه استاذ عمار اهلا
وسهلا بك اولا جديد المشهد الميداني اذا
كان لديك اي داله وهل يمكن القول ان
ننهدنا ما زالت قائمه برغم بعض الخروقات
نعم يعني قبل قليل كنا نستمع الى عدد من
الاشتباكات المتفرقه والمتقطعه في منطقه
وسط العاصمه الخرطوم وهذا ما يشير
قتل القياده العامه للجيش ومنطقه القصر
الجمهوري وما زالت عدد من اعمده الدخان
تتصاعد في هذه المناطق وقبل قليل ايضا
طلعنا بيان نشر لقوات الدعم السريع والتي
اشارت فيك لانها سعت من جديد الى تمديد
الهدنه لمده 72
مرات انسانيه مجددا
لتمديد الهدنه بشكل واضح ومن جديد على
المستوى الميداني ايضا هنالك عدد من
المصادر تحدثنا اليها اشارت الى ان ربما
اشتباكات متقطعه في منطقه غربي وام دربان
وهذه المنطقه معروف انها منذ الليله الامس
تشهد عدد من الاشتباكات في هذه المنطقه ما
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريعه هذا هو
الجديد الان على ارض الميدان مع مرور هذه
الليله وهذا اليوم ايضا يعني والحديث عن
هدنه جديده ننتظر بيانا قوات المسلحه في
الموافقه على هذه الهدنه او تمديد هذه
الهدنه او ما سوف تحمله ساعات القادمه
يعني يمكن القول هنالك تفاؤل بامكانيه
تمديد الهدنه الاثنتين وسبعين ساعه اضافيه
عمار ام لا حتى الساعه يعني
الامور تدعو الى التشاؤم اكثر من التفاؤل
بالتاكيد التفاؤل هو الحاله الاكبر رغم ما
نمر به من كثير جدا من الصراعات
والاشتباكات الدائره لان هذه الحرب لابد
ان تتوقف ولابد ان تذهب بعيدا مثلما اتت
وهذا هو راي كثير جدا من الذين استطلعناهم
والذين تحدثنا
اليهم رغم من رغم الجراحات ورغم كثيره جدا
من الالام يبدو التفاؤل ايضا موجود وبحيز
كبير ويبدو الامل منفتحا نحو عوده المجتمع
وعوده السلام
للاحياء من جديد هذا رايي واضح وصريح
هنالك من يرى ايضا ان قضيه الحسم العسكري
لابد ان تكتمل الى نهايتها من الطرفين هذا
الراي وهنالك من يرى بظروف التوقف والعوده
للحوار والعوده للمفاوضات وهذه كلها
سيناريوهات يبدو انها مطروحه في الوقت
الراهن طيب عمار بالنسبه الى ما اثير عن
وحدات الامن الشعبي ودخولها في المعارك
واتهامات من قوات الدعم السريع ونفي من
قبل الشرطه السودانيه حقيقه ما يجري فيه
في هذا الخصوص
يعني هذه النقاط تحتاج لكثير جدا من الدقه
وتحتاج لكثير جدا من التحقيقات والتحري
عنها بشكل او واضح وبيان الشرطه قبل قليل
او قبل ساعات من الان اشار بوضوح الى ان
هذه القوات معروف انها تتبع لقوات الشرطه
وحتى اشار الى احد الاسامي التي كانت قد
تم يعني زوجها في هذه القضيه بانها تتبع
الى الامن الشعبي وتتبع الى الحركه
الاسلاميه او تتبع الى التنظيم الاسلامي
ومعروف يعني ان هذه الفرقه فرقه الاحتياط
المركزي وهي تتبع للشرطه منذ زمن باكر هذا
يقود ايضا الى ربما الحرب التصريحات ما
بين الجانبين وحرب التضارب التي او عمليه
التضارب التي نشاهدها بشكل واضح ولكن هذه
القوات الان من بحسب ما تابعنا وبحسب ما
نشر عنها انها انتشرت قوات الاحتياط
المركزي يعني انها انتشرت في عدد من
المواقع واما نتعدد من المناطق وبالجانب
الاخر او تتحدث قوات الدعم السريع بانها
قوات تتبع للامن الشعبي لابد يعني حينما
يتم التحدث بمثل هكذا او بالجانب الاخر ان
تثبت او ان تقدم البراهين والدلائل حتى
يعرف الراي
حتى نستبي من ذلك لابد من التحري في مثلها
كذا قضيه حتى نذهب وراء راي معين من
الخرطوم الصحفي عمار ابو شيبه شكرا لك
عمار على كل هذه المتابعه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات